Leo loves bringing his mom as his date
in 2005 he also brought then girlfriend
Gisele Bundchen I got my mom and my
girlfriend with necessary routing for me
tonight so I got a good support system
when he finally won last year for the
revenant after five previous nominations
his german-born mom was on cloud nine I
was so happy have no idea very very
happy he's with Matt Damon Ben Affleck
are still nude on Hollywood with their
mom for their days Matt's mom Nancy even
got to meet a screen legend and you just
gotta go all when a star brings his
mother on the Oscar red carpet when he
won for Dallas buyers club Matthew
McConaughey made sure to thank
to my mother who's here tonight who
taught me and my two older brothers
demanded that we respect ourselves and
what we in turn learned was then we were
better able to respect others thank you
for that moment when Ryan Gosling was a
nominee in o7 mom Donna and sister Mandy
were by his side at the Oscars and as
the day before at the Spirit Awards good
boy
has he been sending a good brother and
he's got his priorities straight and
proud back when Bradley Cooper was
nominated for silver linings playbook he
was nervous about bringing his mob
Lauria to the ceremony she's exciting
she's excited you know we haven't found
hasn't found the dress yet is she
nervous about yes yeah I mean I'm gonna
be the caretaker that night well she
found the dress I just pulled it out of
my closet I didn't really go crazy and
that ostrich feather gown proof she's
quite the fashionista right down to the
shiny sneakers on her feet
[Music]
you